do you really want to change your life
for the
better it can happen but it will require
discipline and sacrifice to get out of
your comfort
zone because you cannot continue to do
the same things over and over and expect
things to change they
won't Albert Einstein said insanity is
doing the same thing over and over
again and expecting different
results moving out of your comfort zone
is the first step
you need to take to
change and you should not waste any
time time pauses in an
instant you are but a
vapor one day you're here and the next
you are
gone life is short so don't waste
yours
far too many people come to the end of
Their Lives full of
regret if only I did this if only I did
that they are
alive but don't really
live you are Your Own Worst
Enemy if you have dreams they will stay
dreams if you you don't actually plan
and work for it how many years do you
need to finally change every year that
passes you have New Year resolutions and
it goes well for the first few weeks but
then you fall back into your old
habits that is the problem because there
should be life resolutions and not New
Year
resolutions it must be a lifestyle
change if you truly want to change for
the
better it requires sacrificing temporary
things your flesh wants to do in order
to reach that which is most important in
life this will change your
habits and your habits will change your
routine and your routine will bring you
consistency and consistency will bring
you lasting
change but what if it is the wrong kind
of lasting
change what if what you think are your
perfect dreams are not actually going to
bring you true
purpose fulfillment and
peace it might not be what you thought
it would
be what if when you reach the peak of
the mountain that Peak is not what you
thought it would be at
all and what do you do next search for
another
Peak then another and another until you
die what is the meaning then of life if
all there is to it is to be
born then to move from one goal to the
next and then die we hundreds of years
from now nobody will even remember your
name here's the answer this temporary
world you are living in is like the
Matrix the real world that exists around
you is the spiritual world with angels
demons God the the devil Heaven and
Hell and this is the Eternal world that
you will enter when you
die this life is like a drop in the
ocean compared to eternal
life you are mainly here to make a
decision given the breath of life to be
alive and make a choice from your own
self-determining will to choose the
white pill or the
black to choose the
light or the darkness to choose God
or the
devil and when you made your choice you
will either be with God in heaven or
with the devil in
hell because that is what you
chose in this short temporary World
there is only one Pursuit that actually
matters The Pursuit Of God which is the
pursuit of Truth the logos the Alpha and
the
Omega The God Who made the world and
everything in
it being Lord of Heaven and Earth does
not live in temples made by man nor is
he served by human hands as though he
needed anything since he himself gives
to all mankind life and breath and
everything and he made from one man
every nation of
mankind to live on all the face of the
Earth having determined a lot of periods
and the boundaries of their dwelling
place that they should seek God and
perhaps feel their way toward him and
find him yet he is actually not far from
each one of
us for in him we live and move and have
our
being stop wasting in your life from
this year
forward and focus on the one thing that
matters
most in my book bold Pursuit and 90-day
devotional for men seeking the heart of
God I wrote on day 82 on average 333,000
people die every day we don't know when
we'll be part of that statistic we can't
take life for granted
and we can't ignore what comes
next Hebrews 9:27 says it is destined
for people to die once and after this
comes
judgment to prepare for the end of this
life we must first make sure that we
will spend our next life In God's
Presence
forever God gave you a self to think on
your own a self-determining power by
which you can choose what you want to do
with your
life why did God give this to
you because he wants you to choose to
seek him to know him
personally to love him and to oby
him he is your your Creator and he loves
you he wants you to bring yourself to
him so he can bless you with his
fullness and lead you forward in his
will this is the key to living a life of
total Victory a life of complete
surrender and a life of purpose
fulfillment and unconditional
peace you can pursue a lot of things
from this year forward a healthier body
money relationships and
power but it is all temporary and will
fade away only one Pursuit brings true
satisfaction on
Earth because only one Pursuit matters
for eternity becoming a true man of God
so what will you choose the black pill
or the white
pill the choice is
yours